determine the domain and range for the
relation
described by the table
and so what they want us to say what
they want us to figure out when they say
the domain they're saying what are all
of the possible
inputs that we could put into in this
case a relation and later we'll see into
functions and so over here or i guess
one way to think about it what are all
of the inputs that this relationship is
defined for and so you can view the x as
the inputs so when x is negative 1 y is
3 when x is 3 y is negative 2. when x is
3 again now y is 2 and that's why we
can't describe this as a function here
because we have two different y values
for a given x value but it can be a
relation when x is 4 y is 8 when x is 6
y is negative 1. so to answer the first
part when they ask us what is the domain
what is the domain of this relation
they're really just saying what are all
of the inputs what are all the x values
for which this relation is defined and
they list the x values right over here
so it is the set and that's what these
curly brackets mean that i'm about to
describe a set it is a set of the
numbers negative 1
and 6.
so all we're saying here is if we say
the domain of this relation is these
four numbers it says that any of these
that this relation is defined for any of
these four numbers if you give any of
these four numbers as an x value there
is a y at least one y value associated
with it now when they talk about the
range when they talk about the range of
this relation and the idea also applies
to functions which are more specific
class of relations
you can view them as kind of a
well-behaved relation the range is what
are all of the possible outputs that
this relation can give you or given
given the given the inputs what are all
of the possible values that this
relation can take on so here you'll take
it look at all of the possible y values
that it can take on so we can get and
i'll write we could write them in order
or we don't have to write them in order
but i'll write them in order just for
the sake of it actually let's just go
straight this way it doesn't have to be
an order a set does not imply some type
of order it just means a collection of
things so the range here well our y
value can take on the value three it can
take on the value negative two it can
take on the value two it can take on the
value 8 and it can take on the value
negative 1. and we're done these are
these are the x values for which this
relation is defined that you can
actually find an association or
relationship and these are all the y
values these are kind of all of the
outputs of the relation that it can take
on and we just looked right over here to
find them